"Mission: Impossible — Dead Reckoning Part One"
has perhaps the most terrifying
enemy of the entire franchise,
and it's inspired by a very possible dark
future for our society. Warning: Spoilers ahead.
Over the course of the first six
"Mission: Impossible" movies,
Ethan Hunt has battled terrorists,
rogue agents, and plenty of villains
bent on world domination. But he's never faced
anything quite like his new foe in "Mission:
Impossible — Dead Reckoning: Part One."
In the franchise's seventh installment,
Ethan and his renegade IMF crew face off against
the Entity, a malicious AI with shadowy plans of
world domination. The digital demon is a
brilliant, cunning, and sadistic enemy,
and though Ethan ends the movie one step
ahead of it, the Entity is far from defeated.
What exactly is the Entity? As explained in the
movie, it's not just one AI, but a network of
them. At one point, it's described as having
multiple personalities, all working as one.
The Entity was created to be a much simpler
A.I., but after being left to its own devices,
it evolved, went "mad," and set its sights, for
reasons yet unknown, on taking over our world.
The Entity may have no physical form, but its
powers are still frightening. Its main weapon
is information control. Throughout the film, we
see the AI impersonate different characters over
voice calls, erase people's faces from security
camera footage, and infiltrate basically every
advanced database in the world, demonstrating
its incredible prowess. Still, the Entity has
yet to make its big move, leaving much of its
mission and motivation still shrouded in mystery.
"You have no idea the power I represent."
For most of the movie, the origins of the Entity
are left unclear. We first see it plugged into
the computer system on a Russian submarine.
Which it promptly destroys and escapes. That
would suggest that the Russians were the
ones to create the AI, a theory that seems
to be supported by the later bafflement of the
United States intelligence community. However,
at the end of part one, we learn that
the Entity was actually made in the U.S.
Director Denlinger, a previously unassuming
intelligence official, reveals to Gabriel in
the film's final act that the Entity was created
as a tool of the U.S. government. Its placement
on the Russian submarine was a kind of test
run. The AI's handlerl s wanted to see if it
could effectively disrupt the sub's stealth
systems. However, things went wrong when the
Entity developed a mind of its own, destroyed the
submarine, and vanished into the digital void.
Denlinger reveals that he has villainous
plans for the Entity, wishing to use it to
overthrow the U.S. government and create
a global fascist superstate to rule the
world. Whether or not this was always the
plan since the AI's creation is unclear,
but given how few other U.S. intelligence
officials know of the Entity's origins,
it seems likely that Denlinger was operating
in relative secret before his death.
For as much as "Dead Reckoning
Part One" reveals about the Entity,
there's far more that we still don't know by the
end. We don't know how it got on the Russian sub,
where the mysterious keys that control it came
from, or why its mainframe can still be accessed
through the sub's wreckage. We don't know how or
why it struck up a relationship with Gabriel. And
beyond all of those logistical questions, we still
don't really know what the Entity truly wants.
Near the beginning of the movie, we learn
that the AI intentionally infiltrated every
major intelligence database on Earth, a sort of
announcement to the governments of the world that
it could dismantle them at a whim. However, the
Entity then retreats, spending most of the movie
messing with Ethan Hunt and the IMF. Does it want
what Denlinger wants, to subdue the world under
an oppressive regime that controls the very
flow of truth? Or are its plans more complex?
Only "Mission: Impossible — Dead Reckoning
Part Two" can answer these questions. For now,
we're left only with the mystery
of what the Entity might do next.